what if I told you that sukuna is not
just one person and that he may have a
secret brother who is going to change
everything in the Jiu Jutsu Kaizen story
some believe that t sukuna is so strong
because he devoured his own brother and
his brother's power While others believe
that his brother is still out there
somewhere waiting to be resurrected but
the craziest of all is the theory that
Kaku created Yuji in order to turn him
into a vessel for The Reincarnation of
the other sukuna Yuji could be sua's
long lost brother and we got to talk
about it right now you guys know how
this works if you enjoy our jjk content
and you want us to make more leave a
quick like and comment right now for
that YouTube algorithm and if you want
to help this channel attain special
grade status by hitting 2 million
subscribers do me a huge favor and
subscribe right now we are really close
finally this video will contain jjk
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned the really
cool thing about jiujitsu Kaizen is that
many of its most powerful characters are
based on actual mythological figures
from Japanese history and folklore I
recently made an entire video on how the
truth about Gojo's rebirth may have
already been foreshadowed through the
life of michan sugara satarug Gojo's
ancestor and the progenitor of the
entire Gojo Clan but Ren sukuna himself
is also based on a mythological figure
from our own world this mythological
sukuna is first mentioned as early as
720 ad which is over 1,3 300 years ago
this actually predates the Haan period
of Japanese history meaning that sukuna
can be traced back to the older Nara
period And even in those portrayals from
the NADA period he was said to have
lived hundreds of years earlier maybe
even as early as
377 ad it was during the NADA period
that an extremely important historical
document was compiled and this is the
document from which G seems to be
getting a lot of his inspiration for the
jjk story the name of this document is
the hon Shoki also known as The
Chronicles of Japan this is believed to
be the second oldest recorded text in
Japanese history and it contained a
detailed record of the history of Japan
up to that point now it's important to
note that back in that time it's hard to
distinguish history from folklore and
mythology because people from back then
believed that myths and legends were
historical facts and mythical creatures
and even Gods actively influenced the
human world the sukuna who is mentioned
in this text has four arms and two two
faces which is similar to R and sua's
final form in Jutsu Kaizen but the
sukuna from the Nihon Shoki also has
four legs he was described as extremely
tall over 3 m and he was set to possess
superhuman combat abilities the nion
Shoki portrays sukuna as a being that we
fans of Jutsu Kaizen are quite familiar
with he is described as an evil mass
murderer who defied the emperor's wishes
and decided to rebel against him since
the emperor was believed to have a
divine mandate from Heaven any Rebellion
against him was immediately considered
evil and demonic and sukuna was blamed
for the deaths of tens of thousands of
people due to his sinful decision to
oppose the emperor sua's rebellion was
finally tarted after the emperor sent
his Shogun Tak fukuma no Mikoto to kill
him and since he was such a dangerous
enemy of the emperor for centuries to
come he would be presented as a demonic
murderer who killed and even devoured
thousands of people a symbol of evil
aggression and Chaos a living natural
disaster a walking Calamity even to this
day this is the prevailing image of the
mythological sukuna in modern day Japan
so it makes sense that the character of
sukuna introduc to Kaizen would be
portrayed in a similar way but did you
know that there is a completely
different side to the sukuna story if
you look at the local Legends of the old
Heda Province Today part of the gefu
prefecture in Japan there is a
completely different sukuna that emerges
Heda province is allegedly where the
evil sukuna launched his Rebellion
against the emperor back in ancient
times but even to this day some locals
in that area worship and venerate sukuna
as a benevolent Guardian to the locals
of this area sukuna is not some demonic
murderer instead he is portrayed as the
person who introduced Buddhism to this
region and according to local Legend he
protected the people of Heda from
Monsters including an evil dragon in
these circles sukuna has even been
referred to as the Incarnation of Canon
the bodhisatwa of compassion and mercy
which is among the highest forms of
Praise that you could ever bestow upon
anyone within the Japanese Buddhist
tradition so what is going on here it's
like there are literally two completely
different sukuna one is a benevolent
Guardian who preached Buddhism and
compassion and who risked his life to
protect the local people from Monsters
the other is a demonic Mass murderer who
tried to overthrow the divinely
appointed Emperor and plunge the entire
country into chaos you might be tempted
to think that we're talking about
totally different people who just
happened to share the same name but
since we're talking about the same time
period and the exact same part of the
country that is unlikely as we all know
history is written by The Victors and
one theory about sukuna true Origins is
that he was a local ruler of Heda
Province who tried to protect the
province's independence by resisting the
expanding rule of the Emperor
essentially he wanted the local people
to govern themselves instead of being
subject to Imperial Rule and since that
historical text I mentioned earlier the
Nihon Shoki was compiled by the emperor
and his family they made the conscious
decision to literally demonize sukuna
even though sukuna might have actually
been loved by his own people because he
dared to oppose the emperor and his
divine right to rule sukuna was
presented as a bloodthirsty mass
murderer and a walking Calamity that
threatened to destroy all of Japan when
you really think about it it's easy to
understand how something like this could
happen the emperor believed that he had
the god-given right to rule all of Japan
and every local ruler had the duty to
Bow and Obey but the people of H
Province may have seen the Imperial Army
as Invaders who were trying to take away
their independence and force them into
servitude the locals saw sukuna as their
Guardian someone who fought for their
freedom against an invading Army against
an evil dragon on the other hand the
Loyalists of the emperor saw him as a
menace who was rebelling against the
authority of the heavens themselves both
things can be true at the same time just
depending on which perspective you take
and since the emperor's forces has
ultimately won out in the end they got
to write the history books literally
they wrote the Nikon Shoki and they
described sukuna as an evil demon most
of Japan eventually accepted this
version of the story and only a few
locals inside of heita province
remembered the truth about sukuna and
that is why they continued to quietly
venerate him I really like this idea of
their being too completely different
sukuna even though they are the same
person the difference is only in which
perspective you take but at the same
time it's possible that sukuna really
was two people and that he might have
had a brother who fought alongside him
in his war against the emperor it's kind
of strange that the Nihon Shoki
describes sukuna as being a 3 m tall
monster with two faces four arms and
four legs it's almost as if sukuna was
two people fused together which is what
made sukuna so much stronger than a
normal person now if we assume that the
historical sukuna like the one who is
mentioned in the nioki wasn't an actual
inhuman monster then we have to ask
ourselves where this idea of someone
looking like two people fused together
even came from could it be that the
rebel leader of H Province sukuna was
actually two separate individuals
perhaps two brothers who fought together
as one in fact maybe they fought
together so effectively that to their
opponents it seemed like they were
fighting a single monstrous enemy with
four legs four arms and two faces one in
front of his head and one on the back I
could totally see these two brothers
standing back to back and fighting
together with Incredible coordination
which made the enemies who are rushing
at them feel like they are fighting one
massive monstrous body one single
superhuman man and especially if they
are brother who look alike or maybe even
identical twin brothers who look exactly
alike this would further promote the
narrative that this was one demonic
person instead of two extremely skilled
and highly coordinated Warrior brothers
so at least in terms of the historical
sukuna this could be the explanation for
why this legendary individual has such
an unusual double body it makes sense
for the Nikon Shoki to promote this
Narrative of sukuna being a single
monstrous enemy because that sends the
message that only an inhuman demon would
dare oppose the emperor a normal human
would never even think to do such a
thing so if you happen to have only two
arms and two legs and one face and if
you're not an evil bloodthirsty demon
then you would never even consider
standing against your Emperor but okay
the brother thing could be an
explanation for sukuna unusual body in
our own world and yet the world of Jutsu
kaisen is a fantasy where the existence
of monstrous creatures is possible under
those circumstances maybe we don't need
a brother at all nevertheless in Jutsu
kaisen we have been told that sukuna
started out as human but that he
eventually became the king of curses and
the strongest judu sorcerer in history
so he didn't always have that monstrous
double body he only attained it later
this has led some fans to speculate that
he might really have had a brother but
perhaps he devoured his own brother and
consumed the brother's power which is
why sukuna has four eyes instead of two
four arms instead of two two and two
mouths instead of one it is also why he
seems to possess a second fire-based
innate technique on top of his regular
slashing technique maybe sukuna had a
twin brother that he devoured in the
womb or maybe he was born with a
conjoined twin or maybe he just had a
regular brother but at some point in
history he killed his own brother and
consumed his brother's body and power or
it might have been something less
Sinister than that let's assume for a
moment that sukuna from Jutsu Kaizen was
also a local ruler who rebelled against
the emperor like the mythological sukam
in our own world perhaps he and his
brother fought against the emperor
together but then his brother was killed
and sukuna consumed his brother's body
and power afterwards in order to ensure
that his brother will live on in some
way this could also explain why the
sukuna from jjk became evil after losing
his brother and possibly everyone else
he loved and cared about in that war
against the emperor sukuna stopped
caring about Humanity in general because
all of the humans he cared about were
already dead he wanted revenge against
the rest of the world for what happened
to his loved ones and since he was now
more powerful than ever before he was
able to become the notorious king of
curses the walking Calamity now I think
that something like this would be a
really great backstory for sukuna and it
would add additional layers to his
already interesting character but could
any of this have a real effect on what
is actually happening in the story right
now or is it all just random lore and
World building I think that sukuna
brother the other sukuna could
definitely come into play in the modern
era and in the current Arc of the story
through none other than our protagonist
Yuji itadori we knew from the very
beginning that yuji's body was special
he had super strength he had super speed
super endurance and then when he ate one
of suk's fingers he became the first
vessel that could actually control and
suppress sukuna inside of him he was
able to do this even after eating mult
multiple fingers and Gojo stated that
someone like this appears only once
every 1,000 years in fact Yuji likely
would have been able to control sukuna
even after consuming all 20 of his
fingers as long as he consumed them one
by one and actually spaced them out that
is obviously not how a normal human body
works and mahito gave us additional
Clues when he revealed that Yuji has the
unique ability to actually hurt a
person's soul not just their body makito
also states that Yuji has a unique
understanding of the Contours of a human
soul and then there's the fact that
yuji's Soul managed to survive the death
of his physical body for quite a long
time before his body was eventually
revived by sukuna all of these factors
about Yuji seemed extremely unusual but
everything finally started to make sense
when we learned that Yuji was actually a
human experiment created by none other
than the evil sorcerer Kaku the same
evil sorcerer who helped sukuna turned
himself into a cursed object and then be
reincarnated into the modern era the
same sorcerer who made dark deals with a
whole bunch of ancient Sorcerers and
created the culling game and the same
sorcerer who used human experimentation
to create the cursed wounds as it turns
out kenju is actually yuji's mother more
specifically he took control of yuji's
Mother's body and then went through the
trouble of giving birth to Yuji
obviously kenju would not have gone
through all of that for just anyone so
we know that he definitely had some big
plans for Yuji we don't know what
exactly these plans were but it's safe
to assume that yuji's superhuman
abilities are the direct result of
kaku's human experimentation and there
is one thing that Gojo said all the way
back in chapter 12 he said that as
sukuna vessel yuji's body would
eventually learn how to use sukuna own
innate technique and recent events in
the manga are hinting that this very
thing May finally be happening if sukuna
really had a brother either a twin
brother or regular brother and that
brother somehow died in the distant past
could Kaku be trying to revive him what
if yuji's unique body and his incredibly
rare ability to control sukuna inside
his body came from the fact that he was
created using something that belonged to
Suk kuna's brother either a piece of his
flesh or a cursed object or something
along those lines Yuji could be in the
process of becoming the other sukuna
someone who shares sua's DNA and his
innate techniques and someone who might
have once fought alongside sukuna as his
own brother let's be real Kuku always
knew that bringing sukuna to life in the
modern world would be extremely
dangerous and he knew that once he
opened this Pandora's Box there would be
no way to actually control sukuna if
sukuna decided to go against Kaku for
whatever reason it is entirely possible
that kenju would have no way of keeping
sukuna in line and so all of the plans
that that Kaku spent 1,000 years trying
to bring to fruition would collapse so
what if Kaku created an insurance policy
what if kenju created Yuji as the coming
Reincarnation of sukuna brother the only
person who could potentially stand up to
sukuna in case kaku's master plan became
derailed by Suk kuna's power and
uncontrollable personality what if Yuji
is the other sukuna and what if he has
the ability to not only learn sukuna
innate technique but to also one day
rival sukuna himself in terms of power
and potential if Yuji can learn to use
sukuna aate technique and if he can
combine that with his own unique ability
to affect the souls of others he may
become Humanity's Only Hope of actually
defeating the absolute monster that is
Rian sukura what do you guys think did
sukuna have a brother and did he maybe
consume his brother and take his power
or or could we actually see that brother
reincarnating into the modern world
sometime in the future maybe with Yugi
itadori as his vessel drop all your
craziest theories down in the comments
below if you're looking for an epic jjk
video to watch next don't ignore my
video about how the truth about satu
Gojo's ancestor may have already
foreshadowed Gojo's rebirth link on
screen and in the description if you
enjoy our Jutsu kaisen content and you
want us to keep it coming in the future
leave a quick like and comment right now
and if you want to help this Chann
attains special great status by hitting
2 million subscribers do me a big favor
and subscribe right now we are so close